KENDRA PUGH: Hi.
Let's talk about
object oriented
programming in Python.
First, object oriented
programming is
a programming paradigm.
It's in the same category as
things like functional
programming and imperative
programming.
But object oriented programming
is going to be the
programming paradigm that
describes most of the code
that you're going to interact
with in 6.01.
So it's important to understand
how it works and
how, in particular, you want
to be able to code in an
object oriented programming
paradigm in Python.
So today, I'm going to go over a
quick crash course on object
oriented programming, and also
indicate all the little tips
and tricks you need in order
to program in Python.
Let's look at what I
have written up.
So the most important thing to
remember when you're learning
about the object oriented
programming paradigm is that
everything is an object.
And what I mean when I say that,
and what people mean
when people say that, is that
the ideals behind the paradigm
are that you interact with your
code in the same way that
you would interact with
objects in the
physical world, right?
There's a particular piece
of paper on the
desk in front of me.
And it is a kind of
piece of paper.
So I know how to interact with
it the way you would interact
with any other piece of paper.
If you want to codify this in an
object oriented programming
paradigm, you write
up classes.
Classes are your basic
unit of code block.
They describe what a thing can
do and what a thing has or
what attributes a thing has.
And in object oriented
programming--
frequently object oriented
programming and in object
oriented programming
in Python--
we refer to those things as
methods or functions that a
particular object may have, and
attributes or particular
variables that an
object may have.
Once you've codified what any
object of a particular class
can do, you can then use the
code that you've written to
instantiate an object.
An object is the functional unit
in the object oriented
programming paradigm.
It's the thing that you interact
with, and tell what
to do, and produces
results for you.
It's the thing that makes up--
it and classes those are the
two things that you need to
think about.
But you also have to think about
how they're different.
I have a particular sheet
of paper in front of me.
It has all the properties
of a sheet of paper.
And when I think about all the
things I can do to a sheet of
paper, that constitutes
a class.
But the particular piece of
paper that I have is an
instance of that class.
It's a particular
piece of paper.
That's the gist of object
oriented programming and the
things that you need to know.
Now that I've covered them, I'm
going to go over the most
basic class I could come up
with in terms of object
oriented programming
in Python.
This is a class that specifies
what a 6.01 staff member has
in terms of an attribute
or a method in Python.
If I want every instance of a
particular class or every
staff member of the class, staff
member 6.01, to have a
particular attribute, I
can specify like this.
Every instance of Staff6.01
is going to have
an attribute room.
And that attribute room is going
to be set to the string
describing 34-501,
the 6.01 lab.
If I want every 6.01 staff
member to be able to do a
particular thing, or have a
particular method, or call a
particular function, then
I specify it like this.
This is the beginning of a
method in the class Staff6.01.
It's called sayHi.
I'll talk about self
in a second.
Don't worry about it.
Act as though--
if this is your introduction
to Python programming, then
pretty much pretend
it's not there.
It's kind of like this, but
we'll cover that in a second.
And if any instance of the
Staff6.01 class calls sayHi,
then "hello" will be printed
to standard out.
I have a couple examples up
on the board behind me.
And if you type them into Idle
and see what their return is
like, you'll be able to--
after you've typed in this--
you'll be able to interact a
little bit better with what
Python considers classes,
and objects, and
that sort of thing.
If you look at type Staff6.01,
it'll tell you about a class,
which is an object in itself.
But it's a specification for
instances of an object.
If you want to instantiate
an object that is of type
Staff6.01, you need to use the
parenthesess on the end.
This treats Staff6.01 like a
call and creates an object.
If you just type Staff6.01,
you're just reassigning
Staff6.01 class to the name
kpugh, and that's not useful.
Every Staff6.01 member
should not be
considered a Kendra, right?
Once you have instantiated a
particular object of type
Staff6.01, you can look at the
type of that object, right?
Now you've got one object,
kpugh, myself.
And that is a class
of Staff6.01.
Likewise, now that you have this
object, kpugh, you can
look at its attributes
and methods.
If you look at kpugh.room, then
it should print to the
screen "34-501." That's because
that's the attribute
associated with this instance.
If you call kpugh.sayHi(), it
will use the method in the
class type of this object.
So when you call .sayHi(), it
looks at kpugh, looks at the
type, says, that's of type
Staff6.01, goes to class
Staff6.01, finds the definition
for sayHi(), and
then executes this code.
Hopefully, that all
made sense.
Now, I want to talk
about self.
And you might say, Kendra, I
don't understand where that
comes into play.
And you didn't even
use it over here!
If you're familiar with C++ or
Java, self is a lot like this.
Self is an implicit argument
passed in here.
Even though you specify zero
arguments, it's considered the
first argument.
And you'll probably see a lot
type errors when you're first
programming in object oriented
programming that say that
you've either passed in too
many or too few arguments.
It has to do with this
definition, with self.
Self says, I am talking
about myself.
That's not particularly
intuitive.
But I'll try to explain
a little bit more.
When kpugh calls .sayHi(),
sayHi() always has an implicit
reference to whatever
called it.
When you look at this code,
other instances can call this
code, right?
If I had an instance of Adam
Hartz or an instance of Ike
Chuang they would also have
access to the method sayHi().
And when they called sayHi(),
sayHi() would point back to
the class definition, but also
have a reference to whatever
instance called it.
So when you substitute in this
self, you substitute in
whatever instance called
the method.
That doesn't seem particularly
useful right now because that
class definition does not
actually make any use of the
self, or the ability to use
unique instances of an object
as sort of unique storage
containers.
I'm kpugh.
I'm different from Adam Hartz.
And therefore, I should be
able to have different
attributes, or different
methods, or things that act
slightly differently from the
way they do for Adam.
I'm going to look at a revised
definition of class Staff6.01,
and that definition will use
self in a way that indicates
that you can have different
functionality
for different instances.
It's right here.
Class Staff6.01--
it looks really similar.
In fact, the first two lines
are exactly the same.
We've got a class attribute.
That means that every instance
of this class is going to have
this attribute because it's
a class attribute.
If I want different
instantiations of my class to
have different properties,
then I need to explicitly
address the initialization
of those properties.
In Python, when we want
to do that, we
define the method __init__.
__init__ is a very
special method.
It's got these underscores.
I think it's a protected
keyword.
And it always has the format
"self," and then whatever
arguments you want to
pass in when you're
instantiating an object.
__init__ is not exactly
a constructor.
But for those of you that are
familiar with C++ and Java, it
acts like a constructor.
Immediately after the object is
constructed, __init__ is called.
And all the set up that
is required to set
up the object happens.
So any time you instantiate an
object, all of these things
are going to be executed.
Or all the things
under __init__
is going to be executed.
In particular, we're going to
set the attribute greeting to
whatever argument we
passed in when we
instantiated the object.
So every instance that we create
of this class is going
to have the class
attribute, room.
They're all going to be
in the same room.
But they're also going
to have a greeting.
And you have the option of
specifying the greeting to be
whatever you want.
We're going to make use of this
in the method sayHi(),
which still only takes the
argument self, or the
reference to whatever object
called the method
in the first place.
That reference is going to
get substituted in here.
So no matter which object calls
the method, you will
have access to its particular
greeting using this syntax.
Let's walk through an example.
Let's say I make an example
of Adam Hartz, and he is a
Staff6.01 member.
And his greeting is going to be
"hi." Likewise, let's make
another instance of me using the
new Staff6.01 definition.
Make sure you type this
in because it's not
going to work otherwise.
And make my greeting "HELLO,"
as opposed to just "hi."
If you call the sayHi() method
using hartz, then you should
get a different result then
when you call the sayHi()
method using kpugh.
But if you call the
room method--
or, excuse me.
If you were after the room
attribute of both instances,
then you should get the same
result because this is the
class attribute definition,
whereas this attribute is
specific to each instance.
That's all I have to say for
now about object oriented
programming.
In my next video, I'll start
to talk about inheritance,
which is another really
important property in 6.01 and
also object oriented programming
in Python, and
also has some slip ups.
So I'd like to talk to
you about those next.